Major shakeup today at three media giant
NBC's Universal CEO has stepped down.
Tucker Carlson,
a popular
right wing media
host, is out at Fox News
and CNN anchor
Don Lemon is out after 17 years.
CNN's Oliver Darcy joins us now.
Oliver, let's start with FOX.
Do we know why
they decided to take Carlson
off the network's highly rated show?
A shocking development over at FOX.
Tucker Carlson was the highest rated
single host over at that network he's
been hosting the 8 p.m.
show for several years.
And a sudden announcement today from Fox.
I read you part of it.
Announcing his departure,
it was very short.
It just says
Fox News
Media and Tucker
Carlson have agreed to part ways.
We thank him for his service
to the network as a host and prior
to that as a contributor.
And it goes on to say
that Carlson's
last program already air
to air on Friday.
Even though Carlson on Friday
said that he looked forward
to greeting viewers back on Monday.
Now, of course,
we should point out that Tucker Carlson
was one of the most extreme hosts
over on that channel,
and he's sowed a lot of distrust
in the legitimacy of the 2020 election.
And, of course,
this announcement is coming
just days after Fox News
settled that Dominion
voting systems
lawsuit for a staggering amount of money,
the highest ever
defamation settlement
in the history of U.S.
media. That's known.
And so it's hard
to disconnect those two events.
But the network and Carlson
are not connecting them themselves.
And I should also note
that we reached out
to Carlson several times today,
and he has not not responded
to comment requests.
While there was also
a big development today
at our own network,
CNN Parting Ways with anchor Don Lemon,
another stunning announcement.
This comes earlier today.
This came actually
in an email to CNN staffers from CEO
Chris left over at CNN.
I'll read you what he said in his email.
He said, CNN and Don have parted ways.
Don will forever
be a part of the CNN family
and we thank him
for his contributions over the past
17 years.
And it goes on.
But Don Lemon came out
and he was more explicit.
He said that the network had fired him
and then he
really lashed out and said that
he was hoping that
someone in management
would have had the decency
to tell him directly about this
about this firing.
And CNN PR then put out a statement
separately saying that
what Don Lemon had said
was not accurate
and that Don Lemon did have
the opportunity to meet with management.
So there's a back and forth
playing out
over there at CNN in public as well.
All right.
Let's talk about NBC Universal.
Big news out of there, too.
Big news over at NBCU
where the head of that
company has stepped down
amid a sexual harassment allegation.
It's coming from
CNBC anchor or correspondent
Hadley Gamble.
Her lawyer has put out a statement
saying that after they filed
filed a complaint,
this led to an investigation,
a third party investigation, NBCU,
and this ultimately led to Comcast
Nbcu's parent company
deciding to remove Shell.
And Shell acknowledged
the inappropriate relationship
in a statement of its own on Sunday.
So shockwaves
rolling through the media industry
today, Pam.
Yeah, big day for you
covering all these developments.
Oliver Darcy, thank you.